[Música]
hoy en directo a vamos a la capital
estadounidense porque se llevó a cabo en
la tercera audiencia del comité del
congreso que investiga el ataque al
capitolio del 6 de enero de 2021 la cita
de hoy se centró en el papel que el
entonces vice presidente mike pence
desempeñó en esa jornada en la que
desobedeció las órdenes de donald trump
que lo presionó para que no se produjera
la ratificación de la victoria de joe
biden en las elecciones de 2020
conectamos con cristóbal vázquez
corresponsal de france 24 cristal cuáles
fueron las principales conclusiones de
la audiencia de hoy justamente sobre
mike pence
si precisamente en esta tercera
audiencia a toda la atención está puesta
en lo que hizo el vicepresidente el 6 de
enero del 2021 al ponerse el frente de
el presidente el ex presidente donald
trump y no atender el llamado que le
estaba haciendo para que desconociera
los votos electorales y pues lograra que
don ottón se quedara cuatro años más en
la casa blanca lo que su asesor
greg jacob dijo es que donald trump y su
equipo legal sabía que esto era que era
ilegal que esto no se podía hacer y que
precisamente el abogado que estaba
asesorando a donald trump john eastman
tenía varios planes a pesar de que sabía
que era legal e ilegal y precisamente lo
que resaltó el comité es que tanto sabía
que era ilegal que después este abogado
john isner termina pidiendo el perdón
presidencial el vicepresidente pence
dijo que esta decisión de no hacerle
caso al ex presidente de una tropa había
sido una de las más importantes
su vida y pues el comité resaltó que de
no haber tomado esa posición el vice
presidente mike pence a pesar de que los
manifestantes y simpatizantes de donald
trump pedían su cabeza posiblemente eeuu
hubiera entrado en un caos
constitucional y social cristóbal que
sigue ahora en el proceso cuando será la
próxima audiencia y que se espera allí
la próxima audiencia será el 21 de julio
después habrá otra más este mes el 23 de
julio también se espera que se enfoquen
en temas sobre cómo convoco donoso esta
gran marcha este el día porque no hizo
nada porque no hizo mucho eso varias
horas sentados sin dirigirse a eeuu a
pesar de que sus simpatizantes se
tomaban el capitolio y obviamente como
evitar que esto vuelva a pasar de hoy un
dato interesante más de 20 millones de
estadounidenses estuvieron viendo la
primera audiencia a la audiencia en la
que se enfocó a demostrar como dolor
romperá el centro de este plan para
quedarse en la casa blanca y tomarse el
capitolio y pues entonces estos serán
los temas para tratar en las próximas
audiencias que le repito serán el 21 y
el 23 de junio